all right it is time for Friday feedback
we're calling it Friday feedback now
instead of the mailbag because we are
just regularly incorporating elements
that aren't actually emails and as you
know I want both precision and Clarity
and it is not really accurate to call it
the email bag when we are highlighting
elements from Facebook or Reddit or
YouTube or whatever the case may be so
same stuff new name Friday feedback all
right let's get right into it starting
with some critiques to put it lightly
Wanda wrote in and Wanda says you and
your page must be a comedian slash
comedy because to think Biden is brave
and has done anything good for this
country is sad and blinded well Wanda
you win an award
you are a Critic
who used the correct form of your versus
your correctly using y-o-u-r to show
possession it is my page
I used to say it is almost a requirement
that you use the wrong your when you
write in with hate mail
but Wanda used the correct one now in
terms of Biden is brave and has done
anything good there is a long list of
good things that Joe Biden has done
we've talked about it and it is a very
wide-ranging inflation reduction act
coveted stimulus the attempt to do some
student loan debt relief although it's
now tied up in court getting out of
Afghanistan I think going to Ukraine was
a super interesting and politically
Savvy thing to do laying the Trap around
Social Security and Medicare which
completely upended the way Republicans
were talking about I mean there's a very
long list of things that Joe Biden has
done is he my favorite President is he
the best president was he my number one
pick no but we're trying to be adults
here Wanda please
uh and such black and white thinking is
very very sad Susan wrote in also on
Facebook this is so damn funny I'm gonna
tell you what's going on here okay Susan
wrote to me stay off my effing page
libtard
following it up with Trump 47 go Brandon
and then put by dumb in a nursing home
jail with Hillary Clinton and the Obama
boys Obama yeah
this is a thing that happens a lot there
are non-tech Savvy right-wingers who
don't understand how algorithms work and
as many of you know if you regularly
watch videos on Facebook you might be
scrolling this is me scrolling on my
phone you might be scrolling
and then you're looking at Facebook
video
and it's just showing you things it's
showing you things algorithmically it's
showing you things randomly it's just
showing you stuff and if you don't like
something and you're sort of like a
normal person you just scroll past it
there are people on the right who will
contact us on Facebook who seem to think
that we need to remove our content from
their quote page and that's where you
end up with stuff like this stay off my
effing page libtard now Susan could just
press I don't like this and then she
would never see our content again but a
lot of tech confusion as to you know oh
yeah I'm sitting here saying show Susan
my Clips Facebook please dear God
Michael Rhoden about media coverage of
the grand jury four person in Georgia in
that Trump related uh grand jury and
Michael said David love the show keep up
the great work why isn't anyone talking
about media coverage of Emily cores CNN
literally aired an interview of Miss
core's diver divulging inappropriate
grand jury information then proceeded to
lambast her actions as irresponsible on
Anderson Cooper I would expect a
reputable news Outlet to know better
than to broadcast such inappropriate and
sensitive information does the media
bear responsibility I don't think so no
I think you know if media
Outlets say we're not going to name Mass
Shooters because there's like a specific
reason to avoid glorifying and giving
them the fame that they seek
I think that's totally fine and legit
to say we aren't going to
show
newsworthy stuff that someone else has
chosen to provide
because of how it might impact a case
even though there is no legal issue I I
just see it as very different I don't
think CNN is doing anything wrong it
should be up to the jury 4 person to
decide is it appropriate for me to speak
or not and for whatever
uh Court related authorities to
um manage that but I don't think media
Outlets are doing anything wrong by
showing the interviews Derek also wrote
in about Emily cores and says sounds
like someone close to Trump got to this
woman more tampering nobody in their
right mind would think this is a good
idea except Trump a few people did write
in and say you know David it occurred to
me
that maybe this was something someone on
the Trump side encouraged Emily cores to
do this bizarre media tour knowing it
would be useful to Trump
it's I I understand why people are
making the suggestion uh I have no
evidence that that's what happened but
it would be interesting to look into it
Dean wrote to me about Donald Trump's
plant I think it means plan to eliminate
crime and says hey David someone should
ask Trump if he could eliminate crime in
the U.S
why didn't he eliminate crime in the U.S
during his four years in office you know
it's a perfectly reasonable and sensible
question but if you presented it to
Trump trump would say
that it was because of Democrats
Democrats blocked him from doing it but
if you vote him in next time he'll have
the House and Senate and this time
Democrats won't be able to block him or
you know we often feel in politics that
we have these gotchas and of course
Dean's question is a hundred percent
reasonable why like if why are you now
saying you're going to do all these
great things which you couldn't or
didn't do during your first term they
have an answer they have an end the
point is their followers will accept
that answer
Kevin wrote to me and said David do you
have any advice in regards to particular
methods you find useful to keep yourself
strong in the face of constant terrible
news with Flint Michigan now Ohio it's
become very apparent to me we're on our
own
our leaders Don't Care About Us at all I
find it disgusting that Democrats are
unwilling to speak up at all about Ohio
I don't know that's true and they let
Trump swoop in and act like he gives an
S about anybody other than himself it
was a good move Trump pulled going there
makes him look good it's hard to remain
hopeful when it seems like fascism is
about to fully take hold and has no real
opposition whatsoever keep it up David
hopefully the internet remains intact
and you can continue to upload it's
important to know what's going on
honestly I know that a lot of people
aren't going to like this but honestly
here is what I recommend to keep
yourself sane understand
there's a limit to the number of issues
you as an individual can fix and for
health reasons it's really important to
say this is going to be my intake of
this stuff and that's going to be it you
I've said for me unless I'm like
streaming something on the weekend from
the time I'm done with the Friday show
until I start working on the Monday show
I pay no attention to news and politics
and it is really healthy to set those
limits because you're right Kevin
otherwise it becomes overwhelming in
that way
Ellen Roden and says David you set out
all the reasons why it wouldn't make
sense for Trump to sign the Republican
loyalty pledge but we all know he
doesn't think rules apply to him ever my
guess is it wouldn't bother him to at
least in the least to sign the Loyalty
pledge when it benefited him by getting
him on stage and then turn right around
and run as a third party candidate if it
suits him he'll have no trouble at all
true thing that it was a plot by the
rhinos and he's not bound by it Ellen's
completely correct and in fact I uh
mentioned this on the Monday show
Trump's most likely scenario is if he
has to sign the pledge to debate he'll
do it and then if he loses and wants to
run third party he'll do it and when
people say well but what about that
loyalty pledge sir
he'll say
it doesn't apply because they rigged it
and they stole it and whatever
thorsten wrote in about me taking time
off and says Dear David sir I'm a great
fan of your show and just saw the
mailbag video that's the reason I want
to say something positive about your
supporting your Replacements none of
them are as good as you are that's
because it's your show but all of them
did a very good job it's extremely hard
to replace the front runner of a show
even for a short time of vacation or
parental leave everybody has his own
voice style way of speaking of declaring
something I think you did a good job
with the picks well I appreciate that
and then lastly from TB or TBM
hello David I wish to thank you for not
starting your broadcast with the word so
I've begun to avoid sites that do use of
so to start a broadcast is as sloppy as
what's up everyone
both of these rank up there with at this
point in time or In This Moment both of
which drive me to distraction laziness
has no place in journalism I'm pleased
the malaise hasn't infected your
programs yeah so I guess that would be
like if I started a show with something
like uh
so Donald Trump did another crazy thing
I guess I don't do that I've never I've
never noticed people in general doing
that
but to the extent that TB likes that I
don't start my episodes with so
I am at your service TV TB thank you
very much for uh for letting me know
remember you may be featured in Friday
feedback if you respond to me on Twitter
leave a YouTube comment
respond on Facebook whatever the case
may be and you also of course can
continue to email info
davidpackman.com if you have something
to say we also now have the David Pacman
show in Spanish with where are we from
the standpoint of subscribers where are
we doing on Spanish
right around the 2000 Mark yeah so we
are building the Spanish Channel it is
the same content dubbed into Spanish for
folks who prefer to consume the content
in Spanish you can go to
davidpackman.com
Spanish to find the channel and I will
see you uh next week and uh producer
Pat's on the bonus show today he'll see
you in a moment